They
break
up
This would
the job
and
is that
in China
the
for me
Saturday.
and break
as the fact
a person
of Abdullah
yesterday
and
[Silence]
be
his fact
and of
generations tell us that he was fasting
every single day.
That he was reading the Quran every
single day, meaning the whole thing. And
that he was praying from
right after Isha all the way until
the break of dawn, until Fajr. Now,
remember
these guys had jobs.
They had chores.
They had travels. When we talk about
Abdullah ibn Amr
praying from
Isha to Fajr,
that doesn't mean that after Fajr he was
going to sleep and sleeping until 5:00
at night. No. He didn't just switch his
routine around.
This is to kind of
frame
the exact or or the the intensity of
these men that were around the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
He would be going on 1 or 2 hours of
sleep in every day or less.
Right? They were
you know,
living their normal lives in the dunya
and then every single spare
moment
was spent
with the book of Allah,
was spent in front of Allah making
salah,
was spent fasting.
Imagine not sleeping all night every
single night
and then
fasting
all day the next day
and then making salah the entirety of
the night and during that time of
fasting
reading the entirety of the Quran.
Every single day, even as a young man.
This is incredibly intense.
And so the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam advised him to take it down.
He began with advising him to fast 3
days a month.
Going from every single day, 30 days a
month to less than 10% or 10%, 3 days a
month.
The prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
very well knows that he's going to ask
for more and he's going to require more.
But this is
how the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would
would remedy situations this or
extremes this.
And so
he said, "Ya Rasulullah, inni ajidu
quwatan."
3 days a month, "Oh messenger of Allah,
I am stronger than that."
And so
the prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam,
notice the wording here. Very important
the wording of the narration. This
narration is in Bukhari and Muslim.
He said, "Fast 3 days a month."
He said, "I'm stronger than that."
He said, "Then fast
Mondays and Thursdays." Said, "I'm
stronger than that."
He then said
notice the wording
"Ahabbu siyami ilallah siyamu Dawud."
The most beloved fasting to Allah is the
fasting of Dawud. He didn't say fast the
fasting of Dawud.
Did the prophet himself fast the fasting
of Dawud? No, he did not.
But he did say the most beloved of
fasting to Allah is the fasting of
Dawud.
He would fast 1 day and break his fast
the next.
And so this is what Abdullah ibn Amr
did.
Now when this happened, he was a very
young man.
And he lived for decades after the
prophet's death Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam.
He was narrated at the end of his life
as saying "Laytani akhadhtu bi rukhsati
Rasulillah."
I wish I had taken the allowance of the
messenger of Allah Sallallahu ta'ala.
Meaning it became arduous at the end of
his life. However, the companions
of their
method and of their
of their relationship with Allah is if
they would commit to something, they
would never leave it off.
Till they died.
They committed to something.
Before they commit, they would think it
through.
And then when they would think it
through and commit to it, they would
continue with it until death. And so he
continued with it until old age, but it
took a toll on him.
The next type of fasting or the next
advisable or the next type of fasting in
which the prophet subhanahu wa ta'ala
encouraged or was encouraged to do
generally
is Ashra Dhul Hijjah. It's fasting the
first 10 days of
Dhul Hijjah, which is the 12th month.
Now,
essentially, you're not really fasting
the first 10 days per se.
Why? Because the 10th day is
Eid.
And it's not permissible to fast on Eid.
But it's referred to as the 10 of Dhul
Hijjah or the 10 days of Dhul Hijjah
as
tajawuzan.
it's said the last 10 nights of
Ramadan. It might be night nine nights,
right? This is because it is estimating,
rounding up.
Can I Rasulullah subhanahu wa ta'ala
assume this Dhul Hijjah?
[Arabic recitation]
by Abu Dawud and and and Nasa'i
on the authority of Hunaida ibn Khalid,
one of the
Tabi'in.
And his wife
narrates that one of the wives of the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said
that the messenger of Allah Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam would always fast the
first nine days of Dhul-Hijjah. So, here
we have nine days. They're referred to
as the 10 as, you know, estimating,
right?
just if you were to say
right now the time
is 6:08.
If you were to say it's a quarter past
six,
did you
misspeak or is that a lie
technically? No, it's just estimating.
It's the way people speak, right?
And so, he says he would fast
the first nine days of Dhul-Hijjah. He
would always fast the 10th day of
Muharram, Ashura.
He would always fast at least three days
of every month.
And
he would always fast the first Monday of
every
month and Thursday.
So, that this wife of the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam here
is speaking about his bare minimum
fasting. If we were to say worst case
scenario, what would he fast? This was
his bare minimum. The first 9 days of
Dhu al-Hijjah,
the day of Ashura,
3 days of every month,
and the first Monday and Thursday of
every month. This narration has been
collected by Abu Dawud. Inshallah
starting tomorrow we will be discussing
the next chapter, which is the chapter
regarding the days
in which it is prohibited for a person
to fast. As'al Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
an yu'allimana ma yanfa'una wa yanfa'una
[Arabic recitation]